Salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésors
aujourd'hui.
Pour changer,
on est au bord de l'eau, au bord du canal.
Oui, ça change un beau petit canal
avec un très vieux pont.
Voilà, ça a l'air bien sympa
et ce qu'on va faire, c'est bien sûr
pour changer aussi, pêcher à l'aimant
Oui, visiter le canal. C'est ça.
On est en compagnie de Jade, de Rasta de Sydney
et on va tous jeter nos éléments
en même temps.
Alors, celui qui a la
meilleure découverte, il va payer quoi ?
L'apéro ?
Le café
Allez, ça va,
on prend pas trop de risques.
Attention, un, deux, trois.
Déjà il faut avoir des choses.
Il y a des choses, c'est sûr.
Mais c'est peut être un coup de chance.
C'est plein, c'est plein.
Ben allez-y régalez vous
Qu'est-ce que tu nous sort Jade ?
La barre de fer !
OK, ça commence timidement pour Jade
Il y a quelque chose, c'est déjà pas mal
Une barre de fer et capsule, Quentin ?
Barres de fer aussi.
Rien de très impressionnant pour le moment
Ah ouais, vous avez raison,
il y a plein de choses.
Bon ben je pense que personne ne va payer
le café.
On va juste relancer les aimants
et ça va être très bien comme ça.
On a de la marge. Il y a toute la longueur à faire, regardez
Ça va jusque là bas et il y a un autre pont.
ici beaucoup de vieux objets je pense.
Parce qu'il
n'y a pas de délinquance récente.
Donc qu'est ce que c'est la meilleure
découverte qu'on peut faire à ton avis ?
Des armes de résistants peut être
Ca peut être sympa.
On sent des choses qui sont bien dans la vase quand même.
C'est quoi que tu as Jade ?
C'est quoi un bijou ?
Je ne sait pas trop
Voyons voir
Il y a un truc à l'intérieur avec une croix
C'est un porte clés.
Mais effectivement, dedans il y a quelque chose
un château, non ? Une photo avec un château
Ca y ressemble parce que là, tu vois,
ça fait une croix
Surement un objet religieux
Bien
Très sympa, bien joué Jade
Qu'est ce que c'est ça ?
Une énorme pile ?
Oui, bonne dépollution,
comme dirait Quentin.
Ouais, un couteau !
Pas super mais c'est pas mal.
Opinel quand même.
C'est de la marque.
Il est bien conservé, c'est de la qualité
Jade a trouvé une grosse pile.
Bravo, belle dépollution.
Duracell
Il y a un mec qui vous a reconnu
Ah ouais ? Comment tu sais ?
Il a souri parce qu'il a tout de suite regardé
Un leurre de pêche.
OK, il est devenu noir
mais il est encore utilisable je pense
Des sous encore !
Combien ?
Ce sont des vœux ça ?
5 centimes d'euros
Elle est propre
OK, bien joué
Vous arrêtez de ruiner les vœux des gens ?
J'ai failli me claquer le doigt
ça a été filmé
C'est dangereux, ça,
En tout cas, on a une belle vue de ce pont
Une pile.
Encore une Duracell.
Belle dépollution.
Aie, ca pique
OK, ça c'est un aimant rempli
Oh ! Un porte monnaie
Il est super ancien !
Il y aura des francs alors
Franchement, le porte monnaie,
il a 100 ans, on dirait
J'ai le même, c'est une petite foufoune
Il y a quelque chose dedans.
Venez !
Il est rempli de bijoux
J'adore
Ça n'a pas l'air trop abimé, ça a l'air en bon état.
Regarde, pour le temps qu'il a passé
dans l'eau
On dirait de l'or.
Oui, parce que l'or, ça devient rose comme ça
même celui là il est en bon état
Quand on voit l'état du porte monnaie et des objets avec
Je ne sais pas si c'est en or, il faudra regarder
Ce sont des boutons de manchette
Ah, une médaille
Sainte Rita, Protégez nous toujours.
Protégez moi
toujours Sainte-Rita, ça, c'est religieux.
Un petit icône
Ils sont super bien conservés.
C'est une pince à cravate
C'est le l'or ou plaqué ?
Je me pose des questions les gars
Réponse en fin de vidéo
C'est incroyable
Bien joué !
En fait, c'est que c'est un ensemble, il y a un petit pins
Il va avec la pince à cravate
je suis d'accord pour payer le café
Ben là, c'est toi la meilleure trouvaille
Même le porte monnaie est très joli, on va laisser tout dedans
Bravo
Ça commence bien.
En plus, il y a peut être écrit quelque chose dessus
Je vais regarder, il faut bien décaper
Ici on a quelque chose de super bizarre
et surtout de super lourd
Il y a un gros grillage
Tu veux de l'aide ? On dirait un piège
Ouais un piège pour les poissons, ça non ?
Pour les écrevisses
Il va me falloir un deuxième aimant je pense
J'arrive
Je me dépêche, tiens bon
J'attend
On va essayer carrément en dessous.
Là il va commencer à être plus lourd
Je ne sais pas si il va s'aimanter par en dessous
Il faudrait un troisième aimant je pense
Il y a un gros sachet en dessous.
C'est lourd.
Il y a quand même un gros sachet Quentin
Ca peut être intéressant à sortir et à fouiller
C'est une couette ?
On dirait un sac en toile de jute.
Je crois que c'est super lourd parce que c'est une couette gorgée d'eau.
Tant que ce n''est pas des animaux dedans, je m'en fou
Non, on dirait pas du coup
Sinon je pleure
Bonjour
Non, ce n'est pas aimanté cette partie
Il faudrait attraper un autre aimant pour bloquer la couette au milieu
Le sorte de sac est retombé
Un étendoir à linge
Merci pour l'étendoir
Le grillage aussi il est retombé
Ca va être compliqué de le retrouver
Il faudrait le coincer entre nos deux aimants
Il y a un truc aimanté quand même, parce qu'il se soulève un peu
C'est un miroir ?
Ou une horloge ?
Un plateau.
Juste un plateau ?
C'est bien une horloge.
Ah oui, c'est troué au milieu.
Sympa, un bon frisbee.
J'allais le tester, mais il y a une voiture
Il y a beaucoup de capsules aussi
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est là dessous mais c'est bizarre.
Je vais continuer à le travailler,
il est juste là
A chaque fois que je passe là dessus
c'est rempli.
C'est très bizarre.
On va essayer de coincer nos aimants
entre les deux cordes.
Le sac, il est là, au milieu.
Je ne sais pas si vous le voyez à l'écran.
Ma première trouvaille sympa ! Un ciseau
Bravo, bien joué
Neuf en plus
Tu crois qu'il fera l'affaire pour couper les orteils de Quentin ?
Il sera bon pour les ongles de Quentin.
C'est trop bizarre
On a perdu le lustre
mais au moins on sort la couette.
Il est peut être encore accroché
Oh le poids que ça fait !
Qu'est ce que c'est que ce machin ?
Attention de ne pas te tremper
Jade, tu veux un lustre ?
C'est pour chez toi Quentin, il n'y a aucun lustre.
Ça, c'est une perruque avec des cheveux roses
C'est un déguisement d'Halloween.
On dirait
On a un joli lustre.
Le lustre n'avait rien à voir avec la couette je pense
Quelle est l'utilité de jeter ça dans l'eau ?
C'est un beau lustre en plus
Belle trouvaille
Il n'est pas aimantable en plus
Il ira bien chez Quentin
il n'a aucun lustre.
J'ai quelque chose de bleu là.
Mais oui, je connais ça.
Comment ça s'ouvre déjà ?
C'est rigolo
C'est un jouet
Il me semble qu'il y a une manipulation à faire, de ce style.
Vas y !
C'est pas ça.
Ça s'ouvre, j'arrive à l'ouvrir
On voit les dents du chien
Je n'y arrive pas.
Dites nous en commentaires comment on l'ouvre.
On ne l'a jamais fait ici, c'était d'autres pêcheurs à l'aimant
Vous avez déjà vu du monde ici ?
Oui, oui
Ils sont passés et ont fait plusieurs endroits
OK d'accord.
Ils ont sorti beaucoup de marchandise
Oh ben oui j'imagine.
Il en reste encore un peu mais ça se voit qu'il manque ce qu'il y avait à la surface
Ca a été nettoyé
J'ai trouvé un pochon
Un pochon aimanté
Qu'est ce que c'est ça ?
Une clé avec, d'antivol.
Une visse
C'est un embout de visseuse
Cruciforme
Il est préservé met le dans la poche
OK, cool
Il est fossilisé !
Attends.
Non, non, non
Il ne serait pas tordu comme ça.
Mais si il est vieux ?
J'ai trop cru que c'était une arme
il est mou
C'est peut-être un jouet
Il tombe en miettes regarde
Ouvre le, au point où il en est
Ca me ferait chier si c'en est vraiment une arme
Non mais pour voir si c'est creux
dans le canon.
C'est creux
C'est bizarre.
Il y a une tige
Pourquoi il serait tordu ?
C'est un jouet !
Ne me dit pas que c'est un jouet !
Ne le casse pas !
Ma fausse arme
Si vous avez une idée en commentaire,
c'est vrai que c'est bizarre.
Bien joué Jade
Qu'est ce que c'est ce truc bleu là ?
Un taille crayon
Il n'est pas vieux
Ouais. Moyens
Oui, il est peut être utilisable
Ne tombe pas !
Qu'est ce qu'il fait ?
Des acrobaties
Merci et bonne journée.
T'es prêt ?
Je vous souhaite de trouver de belles choses
Merci beaucoup.
Parce que vous devriez être payé
Merci beaucoup, bonne journée
Bon, je ne sais pas ce que c'est.
Tu en penses quoi ?
Euh, je ne sais pas.
Une genre de poulie
Un morceau de poulie
Je ne peux pas vous aider.
On a quelque chose
Oh, c'est rempli.
Oh là là, une cagette,
Pour ramasser la ferraille.
C'est parfait.
Allez hop,
je vais pouvoir commencer à la remplir.
J'ai quelque chose
Une montre, une montre !
Il est nul ton cerclage de tonneau
Elle a pris l'eau par contre.
Spirit Saint-Louis
Enfin je fais une belle trouvaille
Je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle soit de bonne qualité
Et ça, c'est une cuillère plaqué argent.
Je reconnais
Oui, tu as la même chez toi
Oui, regarde,
ça te plaît ?
Oui
Merci
On vous reprend, on a changé de pont, c'est
le troisième pont de la journée.
On n'a même pas filmé le deuxième
parce qu'il était super propre.
Quentin a trouvé quelque chose au milieu du pont
Ca bouge mais...
Il y a plein de bulles, c'est un gros truc
Il est peut être coincé sur un rocher
Oui
Ha oui il bulle bien
Ca vient !
C'est très lourd.
Ah ben oui, ça vient
Vous avez besoin d'aide ?
Pour l'instant, ça va,
mais c'est lourd
On a besoin de toi aussi Jade
Oui viens, tant qu'à faire
Intéressant
On était plutôt pessimiste pour ce pont
Un pronostique ?
Ca parait assez massif
Peut être de la mobylette
ou un truc comme ça.
Il n'y a pas de trace d'huile
Ça veut rien dire.
Oui, on a besoin des gros muscles.
Tu vas derrière ? Le pouvoir des femmes
Allé
Ah ça a lâché, dommage
J'ai quand même un bout je crois
Ce n'est pas bon signe.
Ouais mais bon, on ne sait jamais
Bon, si c'était magnétique, tant mieux.
Moi aussi,
j'ai peut être quelque chose, on va remonter.
Oh non...
Quel echec
Des choses dont je me serais bien passé.
Je vous reprend dans 45 minutes,
quand j'aurai nettoyé cet aimant
Bien joué
Du calibre douze avec des algues
Et oui, ça, c'est une seule munition.
C'est une sorte de slug
C'est bien
J'ai besoin d'aide
C'est long comme objet
On me le dit tout le temps
Arrêtes !
C'est aussi ce que m'a dit Quentin
Tu m'as volé mon objet
Ton objet je vais le remonter seul finalement. Il n'était pas si lourd
C'était un peu exagéré.
Mais qu'est ce que ça peut être ?
Franchement, je ne sais pas
du tout ce que ça peut être.
Ah ben oui
Un panneau
C'était lourd parce qu'il était plein de vase
Sortie de camion
Mais c'est sorti d'engin que je veux
On voulait sortie d'engin pour mettre dans les toilettes
Tant pis, il faut continuer la pêche à l'aimant
Si comme nous vous souhaitez pratiquer la pêche.
Il faut savoir que les nôtres proviennent
du site de Maison de la Détection.
On utilise les Barbarians
les plus puissants, c'est 1600 kilos.
Mais vous avez différentes gammes
sur le site.
Toutes les infos sont en description
de la vidéo et vous avez aussi
le code promo PECHEURDETRESORS
On a un joli leurre de pêche.
Ça, c'est classique
Même quand les coins sont propres.
En général,
on arrive toujours à en faire un ou deux.
Ils sont très peu aimantés, mais avec les
plus puissants, on n'y arrive pas.
C'est pas vrai mon petit Quentin ?
Certes
J'ai peur
Génial
Elle est belle
Regarde Baptiste
Plein de clous aussi
Il y en a un qui paraît
un peu grand.
Rasta, on est en vidéo.
C'est un burin
Un petit coin pour fendre le bois
Il est ancien en plus
Mais il est petit
On se dit à la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle vidéo de pêche à l'aimant
On a essayé de nettoyer au mieux
les bijoux, mais dans tous les cas,
on peut voir que d'après les poinçons,
ce n'est pas de l'or.
Malheureusement, c'est du plaqué.
Ils sont assez abîmé,
mais ça reste quand même très sympa.